toxic heavy metals have been found in 95
of baby food sold in America we're
talking about lead arsenic Mercury all
going down the throats of babies a
warning now to parents of infants and
toddlers manufacturers selling baby food
with with high levels of toxic heavy
metals should not have heavy elements or
heavy metals in their food particularly
particularly for their children let me
explain so you're a big food
conglomerate and you want to make the
most money possible and the best way to
do that is by using cheaper ingredients
in your food products the problem is
that if you use cheaper ingredients in
adult food products adults will be able
to tell they have developed pellets it
will taste worse of them and they will
stop buying just one simple change like
swapping out milk for soy and suddenly
your best-selling product becomes a
thing of the past adults are picky
eaters this is not ideal but you know
who aren't picky eaters infants and that
is where baby food comes in think about
it babies can't talk and they don't get
to choose what they eat every day
making them your perfect customer you
can use the cheapest ingredients out
there ingredients that may contain toxic
heavy metals and infants will never be
able to tell the difference all you
gotta do is create a baby food brand
that parents trust once you have that
you are golden you can then downgrade
the quality of your baby food over time
theoretically of course making you more
money and no one will ever notice
because it's baby food it's supposed to
taste weird right and if cutting so many
corners leaves behind deadly heavy
metals in almost every major baby food
product Across America more than 100
baby food products were tested and some
of the results may be a little alarming
for parents yeah yeah yeah I know it
sounds bad but a few toxic medals here
and there never hurt anyone right the
toxins can be particularly dangerous Too
much exposure to these particular heavy
metals can lead to lower IQ behavioral
issues even been linked to autism and
ADH eating and Trace Amounts those
chemicals are linked to impaired brain
development and this is why baby food is
the perfect Market segment to sell to
there are always more babies being born
they need a lot of food and parents are
too lazy to make baby food from scratch
which makes processed baby food a staple
in Every Family Pantry just like coffee
water or cereal people need to buy it no
matter what even if there's toxic Metals
in them stay dangerous and this is the
evil business of baby food
[Music]
if you watch this channel you're
probably an ambitious person with a lot
going on in your life that you need to
organize that's why you gotta check out
notion a free productivity app to
replace all your other productivity apps
notion is so powerful and would make
your life so much easier that I just
moved our entire team onto it and trust
me I've tried all the other productivity
apps out there and nothing compares the
notion it is by far the best for most
people which I know is pretty bold to
say what I love about notion is that you
can use it for something as simple as a
notebook to take notes in or as a basic
to-do list or you can scale it up and
use it to manage an entire company like
these companies use it for that's
because notion has the seamless
combination of beautifully formatted
docks tables which are kind of like
spreadsheets but way more powerful
because you can view them in a calendar
view kanban view you can link to your
databases on other pages and you can
organize all this for an entire team to
use this allows you to customize notion
for whatever you're looking for like
this beautiful Financial tracker notion
template made by my friend Hoffer Yang
that you can get for free right now or
this social media planner template made
by the notion team that they actually
use to draft plan and write all their
social media posts that you can also get
for free right now seriously do not
sleep on notion pause the video and sign
up for free right now with the link
below because you will not regret it
again sign up for free with the link
below and thanks to notion for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
look as a big food conglomerate you
definitely aren't putting Arsenic and
lead in baby food on purpose that would
be crazy
you would never do that that's a class
action lawsuit just waiting to happen
toxic Metals in baby food is just a
byproduct of you using cheap ingredients
like rice rice cereal carrots and sweet
potatoes these cheap ingredients usually
grow in the ground heavy metals
naturally occur in the ground in the
water and soil so you end up with toxic
Metals in the most popular ingredients
used to make baby food
October sweet potatoes and corn show of
hands
you didn't know that using cheaper
ingredients has a higher risk of feeding
babies toxic Metals no way we could
never assume that you're just trying to
save money to make baby food more
affordable to struggling families it
definitely has nothing to do with your
bottom line to rice for example rice is
one of the most lucrative and reliable
food products you could ever have
invested in
in 2022 inflation Rose at
record-breaking rates and almost
everyone felt the Ripple effects even
major food conglomerates
the price of almost everything
skyrocketed wheat palm oil soybeans a it
all got ridiculously expensive in just a
matter of a few months that's really bad
for business higher prices cut into your
profits profit margins on food are
already slim enough
tiny change in the prices of your
ingredients and you could go from making
a billion dollars one day to less than
500 million the next
but throughout all of this inflation one
crop was not affected one crop even
dropped in price and that one crop is
rice
so investing in rice-based food products
meant that while food prices for healthy
stuff like fruits and vegetables were
spiraling out of control your products
would remain the reliable cheap
alternative poor people all around the
world would still be able to buy your
products for their kids taking market
share from the more healthy alternatives
that kind of insurance is worth a tiny
dash of heavy metals wouldn't you agree
it's why rice is so popular in food
products including baby food however as
a big food conglomerate it's kind of
hard just to start a great baby food
brand that parents trust right off the
bat a great brand that customers trust
takes a lot of time and work to build
but lucky for you there are lots of
hard-working legit baby food brands out
there who have already put in the effort
into building a great baby food brand
they've done all the organic expensive
nonsense for you already to build a
brand that parents can trust all you
have to do is wave some cash in front of
their face and their Priceless brand
will be all yours
thank you
[Applause]
simply swoop in throw a few million
dollars in the face of these Brands and
then boom now you're free to take over
the operations and do things your way
the cheap profitable way and the great
thing is you can do this without the
parents ever even realizing the baby
food brand they know and love ever
changed hands at all it's almost too
easy so easy in fact that this is the
case for almost every baby food brand on
American shelves right now Gerber is
owned by everyone's favorite food
company Nestle Beechnut is owned by a
Swiss conglomerate hero group Plum
Organics is owned by sun made Growers of
California who bought it from the
Campbell Soup company yes even the ones
with Organic and natural attached to
their name they've all been acquired
walk down the baby food aisle of any
grocery store in America and you'll find
that almost every single one of those
Brands is owned by some giant faceless
big food conglomerate and almost all of
them contain juicy delicious and
profitable toxic heavy metals and the
best part is that no one can do anything
about it even now with it being public
knowledge that these baby products
contain toxic metals that babies around
the country are consuming we are still
in business not even the FDA can stop us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when you hear the title United States
Food and Drug Administration you
probably think that such a big official
institution is obviously out there doing
God's work in the interest of the public
right the FDA is supposed to be
America's go-to Organization for
wrangling in Greedy corporations to make
sure what we put in our bodies is safe
it is the federal agency in charge of
regulating food after all the one that's
supposed to be holding billion dollar
companies accountable so they don't
poison the entire population but you'd
be wrong because the truth is the FDA
actually works with big food they set
limits for just how much bad stuff you
can have in our baby food and get away
with it carefully thought out limits
that still allow us to profit like with
rice cereal for babies only 100 parts
per billion of arsenic in that and it
makes everyone feel like that's how much
arsenic people can ingest without it
being bad for you
reality it's how much the FDA lets us
get away with and most of the time the
limits don't even matter take Walmart as
an example when they were getting looked
at for having too much arsenic in their
baby food according to their company's
own internal standards they just
arbitrarily changed the rule to allow
four times more arsenic in their baby
products without offering any
justification for it the FDA is in
keeping you in check more often than not
you're the one calling the shots look at
the facts even when we do end up with
more bad stuff in our baby food than the
FDA allows like how the top baby food
brands in America right now have more
arsenic lead and cadmium than the FDA
says is safe nobody is coming for us why
because we know the right people in the
right places
owning a big company doesn't just mean
that you make a lot of money it also
gives you the leverage to set up the
rules the way you want them
some major companies have as much power
as a small country take the known for
example they're one of the most massive
Mega corporations in the world with over
25 billion dollars in Revenue about a
decade ago Danone bought a baby food
brand called happy family with one of
the world's top infant food brands in
their pocket they wanted more leeway on
the rules surrounding the baby food
market
I mean why must we have so many pesky
regulations on the food we're giving the
most vulnerable people in the population
so they spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars lobbying against policies that
could potentially get in their way and
in the end they tried blocking three
acts that could have made baby food
regulations stricter and all the other
giant conglomerates that control the
world's baby food you can bet they're
all playing the exact same game
expand
[Music]
when news broke that multiple toxic
heavy metals were found in 94 percent of
tested baby food these corporations knew
they had to act
obviously we didn't really care that our
products were poisoning children we just
had to make it seem like we care enter
closer to zero our handy way of getting
the public off our back for the
foreseeable future the FDA proposed
closer to zero as an action plan in
response to the heavy metal findings
purpose is ambiguous
according to the FDA closer to zero
quote identifies actions the agency will
take to reduce exposure to arsenic lead
cadmium and Mercury from foods eaten by
babies and young children to as low as
possible and end quote and quote our
work combined with that of our
stakeholders has led to meaningful
reductions in exposure to toxic elements
end quote if you kinda just blanked out
as we read that out loud to you that's
okay because we did too the wording is
almost strategic the plan identifies
actions that the agency will take but no
mention of when they'll take action they
aim to keep exposure to toxic Metals in
baby food as low as possible but they
avoid mentioning any specific numbers
our work has led to meaningful
reductions without any actual
information on how things changed
basically it was a message telling the
public everyone calmed down we're doing
stuff now go back to feeding your kids
arsenic crackers
you know we live in a pretty gray world
when even baby food isn't safe from
greedy companies but the baby food
industry is far from the only disturbing
industry in the United States
take the lingerie industry for instance
specifically Victoria's Secret for
decades it's been the most successful
lingerie brand in the world they made
billions from marketing their angels to
the public beautiful young lingerie
models dressed as Angels but behind the
scenes things were much darker
the company's CEO had very close ties to
everyone's favorite Private Island owner
afri jepstein and it's something the
company would rather you not know about
but a public video on this would
probably get demonetized on YouTube
so that's why we released the Victoria's
Secret Epstein connection as a private
documentary that's only available for
members of this Channel and you can
watch it right now by clicking the join
button below once you join you'll also
get instant access to our other private
documentaries ranging from CIA black
sites to MK Ultra to the bin Laden
papers and much more look you can
of thousands of dollars attending
University and leave not knowing
anything about how the world really
works or you could become a member and
get access to all this Insider info for
just five dollars a month and and trust
us it's way more interesting than in
University lectures and there's a refund
policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for your first month after your first
month there is no refund click that join
button right now
hope you guys enjoyed the video today
and if you're new here this is the
channel you go to learn how the world
works and to learn everything that they
wouldn't teach you in school because
there are many things that they didn't
teach in school so if you enjoyed this
video we make multiple videos just like
this one every single week for free so
make sure you click the Subscribe button
below and remember you can always
dislike unsubscribe and leave me your
best hate comments whenever you want so
yeah nothing to lose and everything to
gain you can follow me on Instagram
jaketran but that is going to wrap it up
thanks for being part of the watch the
end Club stay dangerous out there and
I'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
thank you